DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
Hello, everybody.
I'm Wolff Dobson.
This is Bruno.
This is Dan.
We're all going to talk to
you about multiplayer.
But before we get started, we
should think a little bit
about, why do you want to add
multiplayer to your game?
Well, it's fun.
Don't you think?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Lots.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: And when
we talk about fun, we can
talk about fun in a bunch
of different ways.
But one of the ways we can talk
about it is a multiplayer
game that's tuned right will
create a lot of replay value
because you're going to be
fighting, you're going to be
up against the people who are
the most interesting.
It's like the most dangerous
game, right?
You're playing other people.
And that's where it
gets interesting.
And that's how games become
evergreen, like basketball,
which we've been playing
for 121 years.
Like these are the things
that you want.
You want your game to
turn into a sport.
But there's something more
interesting going on here.
You also get discovery.
Your game can use the social
graph, for example, that's on
the phone and on the web
or your tablet device.
And inside that, you get these
very easy-to-send invitations
that go to people that we have
hand-selected to be interested
in your game, which is exactly
what you want.
And that invitation goes
directly to the pocket of the
person that you want
to be targeting.
Now, I think that's
pretty cool.
I know this word gets ever
overused quite a bit.
But I do think we're a very
interestingly disruptive
moment in the games industry.
I'm not always at home.
I'm not always at my desk.
I'm not always at
my gaming rig.
But I always have my phone.
I have one right here.
I have one right there.
My brother wants to
challenge me?
I'm there and I'm up for it?
Just as if he was texting me?
And I think that's really
amazing and a long distance
from like emailing temporary IP
addresses to your friends.
Those are the bad old days.
We're a really tremendous
opportunity for
engagement and discovery.
And those two things--
engagement discovery-- are
really core to maintaining
and creating
a really huge audience.
So if real-time multiplayer is
so cool, why don't we have it?
Well, it's hard.
It's hard for a lot
of reasons.
Let me give you an example.
When I was an indy developer, I
host my game on a pizza box
server down in a data center
down in Santa Clara, that way.
Outside of the time I spent
setting it up and patching it
and making sure it was
maintained, I also woke up one
morning with every single user
emailing me to tell me that my
site was offline.
And when I called Santa Clara,
they told me you'd
better come down here.
And when I went down there, I
discovered, along with many
other engineers standing in the
room, that there had been
a fire in the UPS that
was in my rack.
And I was very lucky to
still have my server
at the end of that.
This is not an experience that
you guys want to have.
You don't want to do
any of this stuff.
There are all kinds of things
you have to keep track of and
build to make multiplayer a
success, things that really
matter, like lobbies
and matching.
And if you get these things
wrong, your multiplayer's
going to be frustrating
and hard to get to.
But doing it right is just going
to cost you guys more
time and money, makes you have
a bigger team than you need.
So we want you to be spending
your time on making your game
awesome, maybe it the unique
value proposition that's going
to make your game huge.
So if you're using it to play
games with real-time
multiplayer, we're going
to take care
of this boring stuff.
And you get to work
on awesomeness.
So it's also available on
millions upon millions of
devices, anything that has
access to the Play Store.
All you need is a Google+
account, which if you have an
Android phone, you're probably
logged into right now.
And it's pretty neat.
And, in fact, it's so need,
we're going take a
look at it right now.
Bruno?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So anyway, we
were trying to make this work
with the actual demo, but since
we couldn't get them to
work, we actually have
a video of this.
So Nostalgic Racer is a
game that we wrote.
And it's very nostalgic
because it
has very big pixels.
And, of course, having big
pixels is a good excuse to
have very low-quality
graphics.
Anyway, this is how
a match is played.
So one of the players is
inviting the other player.
So I'm inviting Wolff.
And then he gets an invite
notification on his screen.
Then he accepts.
And then this is our
waiting room UI.
And now we're playing.
So, as you saw, I picked Wolff
from a list of friends, then
sent the invite.
Then, of course, I win.
Not that I'm competitive
or anything.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Notice
how he made that
movie so that he wins.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So and this is
the final results screen.
So anyway, that was cool
and nostalgic.
But what just happened?
So, Dan, what just
happened there?
DAN RODNEY: My name's Dan.
I'm the TL of multiplayer for
Google Play games services.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about how all this boring
stuff works.
So in the demo we've got here,
Bruno invited Wolff.
And maybe he was going
to invite me, too.
And the way that real-time
communication works when you
use our services is
peer to peer.
We establish peer-to-peer
connections between the
devices in a mesh topology so
that every device is connected
to every other device.
But in order to be able to
do that, first we have to
coordinate things.
So we introduce Google
infrastructure.
And it all starts off when
Bruno's device says, I want to
create a room, and sends a
request to the Google servers.
Now, you may be asking yourself,
what is a room?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So
the classical
definition of room is--
really?
No, that's really,
really boring.
And that doesn't
really matter.
Because the cool thing about
technology is that we get to
choose what the words mean.
So in our context, room is a
virtual place where people get
together to play a game.
And, of course, this
definition works.
But if you're a developer,
you're probably wondering
what's going on actually
behind the scenes.
So then how do rooms work
behind the scenes?
DAN RODNEY: Sure.
So Bruno says, I want
to create a room.
That sends a rest API call
up to the Google servers.
And in that rest API call, in
this case, he's indicating
that he wants to invite Wolff
and myself to participate in
the real-time game.
He could have alternatively
specified that he wanted to,
or additionally specified that
he wanted to, automatch
against other players from the
internet that he didn't know.
But, in this instance,
we're going to say
it's invitations only.
And when that request is
received, invitations are
created on the Google servers.
And these are pulled down to
Wolff's device and my device
using Gsync, which is the
protocol that Google apps like
Gmail use to pull data
down to your phones.
So at that point, notifications
will appear on
our devices.
And when Wolff opens his up
and says, yep, I'd like to
join this room.
I'd like to play with Bruno.
Make a call to the
server saying he
wants to join the room.
That's another rest API call,
which then the server then
notifies Bruno by XMPP that
Wolff has joined the room.
And now using libjingle, which
is the technology that powers
Google Talk, they establish a
peer-to-peer connection by a
combination of XMPP and then
direct peer-to-peer
communication.
After all that's done, they have
this peer-to-peer direct
connection between each other
and can send messages back and
forth using a protocol
called RTP, stands
for Real-Time Protocol.
And that is the protocol that
your game will use to send
messages between devices.
So now, let's say I
do the same thing.
I'd say, I want to join
this room as well.
Then Bruno and Wolff will
get notified that
I've joined the room.
And the same thing will happen
again, where basically we're
establishing peer-to-peer
connections
between all the devices.
And, at the end, we have a
fully-connected set of devices.
So that's great.
Now we can all send messages
back and forth.
But what if there's
a firewall?
Bruno is trying to send messages
to Wolff and myself.
And there's a firewall
or a NAT and we can't
talk to each other.
Fortunately, libjingle has
technology that busts through
firewalls and NATs and makes
it so that 92% of the time,
you can establish a direct
connection between the devices.
The remaining 8% of the time,
there might be a really nasty
firewall that doesn't allow
that to happen, it has a
fallback where messages
are relayed
through Google servers.
So one way or another, provided
you have an internet
connection, you should be able
to send messages to anybody
else in the room.
So now that we know a little bit
about how all this stuff
works, the great thing about all
this is you don't have to
do all that, right?
This is all Google
infrastructure that we've
implemented for you.
And all you need to know is how
do I use the SDK in order
to set up a room and
then start sending
messages back and forth.
And Bruno's going to talk
a little bit about that.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
So for those of you who
love diagrams--
who doesn't love diagrams--
I have a pleasant surprise
for you.
Next slide has a diagram.
It's going to be
a big diagram.
Wait, wait.
I know that some of you are
going, oh, man, a diagram.
This talk's going
to be boring.
Let me walk out of
here right away.
I can actually see some of you
falling asleep as I show this
diagram to you.
But bear with me.
It's actually not as
bad as it looks.
Let's divide this boring
diagram into parts.
So first, just to give a quick
summary, the first thing you
have to do is set up your
game's client, like they
explained in our introductory
talk.
Then they have to sign in, and
they have to check if there's
an invitation.
We're going to come back
to this later.
Next, the user is going to
see your main screen.
So your main screen has a
few options, of course.
They're going to vary
from game to game.
But they usually have
to do with finding
people to play with.
Next phase is getting
people together in a
room to play the game.
This means that you either
create a room or you accept an
invite into an existing room.
And the last part, of course,
is the fun part, which is
playing the game.
And then there's a cleanup.
And then we're back
your main screen.
So let's start from the
beginning, which is always a
great place to start.
So the sign-in has been covered
in the basic games
talk, and there is plenty
of documentation.
So we're not going to
go into depth here.
But just to give a quick
summary, if you are deriving
your activity from base game
activity, which is available
on our samples, the advantage
is that the sign-in flow has
been implemented for you.
All you have to do is override
the onSignInSucceeded and
onSignInFailed virtual
methods.
As usual, when you get the
onSignInSucceeded, you can
start making calls into
the game's API.
One important reminder, though,
if you're trying to
build a multiplayer game,
there's a flag on the
Developer Console that
you have to turn on.
And it's over there.
So it's Linked Apps.
You select your client ID.
And then make sure that
that switch is on.
Otherwise, you're going to see
errors when you try to call
the multiplayer API.
All right.
So we took care of that first
part, except for that last
block that we're going to
come back to later.
Now we have landed on
your main screen.
So let's take a closer look at
what those options mean.
The exact buttons are going
to depend on the game.
But in this simple example, we
might have three buttons,
which is Quick Game, which lets
me play with a random
opponent in the internet.
Then I have Send Invitation,
which enables me to invite my
friends into the game.
And then, of course, we have
Show Invitations, which shows
me the pending invitations that
I have and that I can
accept at the moment.
Let's translate that in terms
of rooms, because rooms are
the new big thing.
So a Quick Game really means I
want to create a room and then
invite a random player
into it.
Send Invitation means I want
to create a room and then
invite some specific people,
presumably my
friends, into that.
And Show Invitation means I want
the game to show me which
rooms I've been invited
into and which I can
get into right now.
So let's start with this part
of the diagram, specifically
let's start with this flow.
So I want to click the Send
Invitation button.
Then what I want to do is select
my friends, so select
which friends I'm going
to play with.
And then I want to create the
room and invite those people.
So to create a room, there are
three things you have to know.
First of all, you have to
know who you want to
invite into that room.
Second question is, what are
the automatch settings?
When I say automatch, I mean
how many random opponents--
that are not your friends,
necessarily--
do you want to invite?
And three, you have to
set up the callbacks.
Those are the callbacks the API
is going to use to notify
you of events.
So this is what we call
a RoomConfig.
So it's an object that
encapsulates the
configuration of a room.
And this is how we create
a RoomConfig.
Actually, this is a RoomConfig
builder, which is a helper
object that helps you
build a RoomConfig.
So this is how we're going
to configure the room.
Now that we created this
object, we're going to
progressively add configuration
into it as we go along.
So first of all, we are ready
to show you the list of
friends so that the user
can pick who to invite.
Of course, you could
just go ahead and
build that UI yourself.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: You can
get a social graph information
from Goolge+ APIs.
You can even sort them.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
You can, essentially, make
your own UI, if you want.
But if you don't want to build
your UI from scratch, you can
use our built-in "Select
Players" dialog.
To do this, first you decide
what's the minimum number and
maximum opponents
that you want.
So that's excluding yourself.
In our example, we're just
trying to set up a two-player
game, so minimum and
maximum are at 1.
And then the next thing is we
get the "Select Players"
intent from the game's client.
So with that intent, all we have
to do with an intent is
just launch it with
startActivityForResult.
And then you're going to see
on the screen the "Select
Players" dialog, which
looks like this.
Notice that I can select
the friends that I
want to play against.
And notice, also, that I can
select Auto-pick Player,
because that's just automatch.
Then I'm going to play
with random opponent.
Notice I can also
mix and match.
I can invite Dan and an
auto-pick player.
Now, when that dialog is
dismissed, you're going to get
the result of the dialog much
in the same way as any other
result in Android.
So that's going to be through
the onActivityResult callback.
So first, we check if the user
cancelled the dialog.
If they did, you do nothing,
of course.
And then if they confirmed,
you're ready to get the list
of players.
The way you get the list of
players from the dialog is you
create the extras bundle, and
then you get the extra players
field from that bundle.
That's going to be the list of
Google+ IDs of the people that
the player wants to invite.
That's easy, right?
Now that you have a list, you
just feed that into the
RoomConfig, and that takes care
of that first part, which
is deciding who to invite.
Now, we're down to the
automatch settings.
So the automatch settings
are in the bundle.
So you have the minimum and
the maximum number of
automatch players that
the players want.
And now that we know that, we're
going to add that to the
RoomConfig as well.
So we create an automatch
criteria bundle using that
helper function.
And then we feed that into
the config builder.
And that pretty much takes
care of the second step.
Now, all we have left is to set
up our callbacks, and we
are ready to create the room.
Now, there are several
possible callbacks.
There are like tens of them.
But in this simple example, all
we care about are messages
that are received, and then room
status updates, which are
stuff like, people joined the
room, left the room, and so on
and so forth.
So we're now done with
those three items.
We have callbacks, automatch,
and who to invite.
And now we're ready to go ahead
and create that room.
So notice that we are passing
the RoomConfig
that we built so far.
All right.
So that takes care of that part,
"Select Players," right?
So we're done?
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Well,
what if I don't care who I'm
playing against?
I don't want to invite
specific people.
I don't want an extra
dialog box.
I just want to play.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: If you just want
to play, and you don't
want to show dialog
of your friends--
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: What if
I didn't have any friends?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: What if you
don't have any friends?
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: I'm
just saying, maybe,
you might not have--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hypothetically.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
--have a friend.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
So if you don't have any
friends, or if you just don't
care who you're going to play
with, you just want to play
right away, you can
entirely skip that
"Select Players" dialog.
And this what the Quick Game
button usually does.
So it sets up a room with one
random opponent, and this
without showing any dialogs.
So this is how you would
implement this button.
So you create an automatch
criteria button using a 1 and
automatch opponent.
Then you build the RoomConfig,
set the callbacks,
and create the room.
Notice that this is exactly
the same as we did before,
except it's easier because we
don't go through that extra
step of showing the "Select
Players" dialog.
So it's exactly the same
as we did before.
All right.
Now, let's take a look at this
from the other side, which is
receiving the invite.
So I'm bored.
I'm looking at my phone,
checking email.
And then, Dan here invites me to
a race in Nostalgic Racer.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Not me.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Which I know I'm
going to win, but anyway.
So what do I see on my screen
when that happens?
So I get a notification on my
screen that looks like this.
So this player wants to
invite me to a game.
And then once I click that
notification, I go to the game.
Now, this is a very
important part.
Because when the game launches,
it should check if
there's an invitation pending.
And if there is, they should
accept it and then go to the
game right away.
This is up to you.
If you fail to implement this
check, the default behavior,
which is the best that we can
do, is just to show the game.
But then, of course, that's a
bad experience for the user
because the user just clicked
accept an invitation.
They don't want to see the
main screen of our game.
They want to get into the
match right away.
So how do you check if there's
an invitation pending
when you start up?
Well, when you get the
onConnected callback or
onSignInSucceeded callback,
you check the
connectionHint parameter.
If the game's being launched
through the system bar
notification, there's going to
be an invitation in that,
which you can retrieve
like this.
Oops.
Seems like I'm missing
part of the slide.
So anyway, you detect that you
have the invitation there.
And then once you have it, you
can accept the invitation.
So to do that, we go
back to old friend,
RoomConfig.builder.
So RoomConfig.builder is going
to be the same as before.
We set up our callbacks.
And then the next thing--
and this is new--
we're going to set the
invitation that we want to
accept over there.
So we're just setting the
invitation that we got from
the connection [INAUDIBLE].
And then we call joinRoom.
So remember that this
is also different.
Before, we had call createRoom
to create a room.
And now we're calling joinRoom
because we want to join an
existing room.
DAN RODNEY: Bruno, I don't have
that many friends, but
ever since I'd been scheduled
to be a Google I/O speaker,
I've been getting hundreds of
people following me, adding me
to their circles.
I think they're going to all
invite me to play games.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's
a big problem.
DAN RODNEY: Yeah, I don't know
what I'm going to do.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Yeah,
big, big problem
DAN RODNEY: I have to have some
place where I can go and
see all those invitations and
then decide which ones of them
I want to accept.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's right.
So for popular people like Dan,
they have to have some
way to see what invitations
they have.
And then Dan can pick and choose
who he's going to play
with first.
And then the other people
have to wait in line
like everybody else.
So how do I check which
notifications are pending, so
which modifications I
have received and
haven't acted upon yet?
What you need is called
an invitation inbox.
And that goes to that
part of the diagram.
So how do you go ahead and show
that invitation inbox?
So it turns out we have a
built-in UI for that.
So you get the invitation
inbox intent calling
GamesClient.getI
nvitation.InboxIntent, and
then you get the intent
to launch that.
Then it goes
startActivityForResult, and
then you launch that intent.
So you're going onscreen
something like this.
Of course, this is
my screenshot.
So I only have one invitation.
But, of course, Dan here might
have screen after screen of
invitations pending.
And then when I click play on
that screen, what's going to
happen is that the dialog is
going to get dismissed, and
you're going to get the
results through
onActivityResult.
So you have to check if
the result is OK.
If the result is not OK, of
course you ignore it.
But then, if it's OK, then it's
going to come with the
invitation ID that you
should accept.
So what do you do with
that invitation?
Well, easy, you just accept it
exactly as we did before.
Actually, this slide was the
easiest one on this whole talk
to make because it's just a
copy-paste of a previous one.
It's exactly the same process.
You set up the callbacks, set
the invitation to accept, and
then join the room.
All right.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: So if I
get invited to a game, I see a
notification on my system bar.
And if I click it,
I get to play.
What if I can't see
the system bar?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Because
the screen is not on?
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: No,
because I'm playing
single-player mode, because
I need to play a lot of
single-player games.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh,
that's right.
If you're playing a
single-player game, maybe it's
running full-screen mode
and you can't see the
notification bar.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
Exactly.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's
a big problem.
So how do you address
that problem?
So if you want your game to
behave correctly in that case,
you have to come to our advanced
session, which is the
perfect time to advertise it.
Actually it's right next, so
if you stick around, it's
going to be the next session.
So if you are in the middle of
game play and you get an
invitation, so you can
actually register an
invitation listener and it's
going to notify you of
invitations, even if you're in
the middle of game play, and
then it can show an in-game
pop-up or anything else to
notify the user that they
have a pending invite.
So definitely, stick around
for advanced games talk if
you're interested in that.
All right.
Now we're done setting up and
getting people together.
Now comes the fun part,
which is, of
course, playing the game.
But wait, actually, before we
play the game, we have to
first wait until everybody's
connected.
So waiting is lots
of fun, right?
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
No, it's not.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: No, waiting's
boring, especially if your
game doesn't do anything
interesting during the wait.
So, for instance, if you just
show that standard, boring
"please wait" screen, the user's
going to be very bored.
So if you are suffering from a
boring wait screen problem,
then it's the perfect time to
advertise our advanced games
session again, which we have
not talked about before.
It's going to be right
here, right next.
We're going to show you how to
implement a waiting room UI to
keep your users happy.
All right.
Now we have to wait for the
onRoomConnected callback with
your boring "please
wait" screen.
That callback tells me that
everybody that I invited is
now connected.
So we're ready to
start playing.
Of course, you have to
check the status code
to see if it's OK.
And if it's OK, you're ready
to start the game.
Now, this is a good place to
store some information you're
going to need later for other
API calls, like room ID, the
list of participants, what's my
own participant ID that's
based on my player ID and--
DAN RODNEY: But, Bruno, what's
the difference between a
player ID and a participant
ID?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh, right, we
haven't explained that.
So what's the difference between
a player ID and a
participant ID?
Well, a player ID is something
that identifies a real person
in real life.
So it's something that's
permanent.
And it's used across games.
Whereas a participant ID
is really temporary and
identifies a player in the
context of a particular room.
So even if the same player is
playing several different
games in several different
rooms, their participant ID
will be different in
each one of them.
So a player ID looks like
a string of digits,
coincidentally and not
coincidentally
like a Google+ ID.
In fact, it is a Google+ ID.
Now, a participant ID looks
kind of like that.
And the way we get one from
the other is we type the
player ID backwards and then put
a cat on the keyboard, and
that gets you the
participant ID.
So long story short, don't
try to parse that.
Don't try to understand
that in any way.
It's just a string.
And we guarantee that it's
going to be unique in the
context of a particular room.
So if you invite specific
friends to a game, they're
going to have both a player ID
and a participant ID because
they're real people.
Now, if you're playing against
automatched opponents, or
random opponents from the
internet, they're only going
to have a participant ID.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Because
they're not real people.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's right.
They're not real people.
They're figments of
your imagination.
Of course, maybe deep down
they are real people.
They have dreams and
hobbies and such.
But to you, that
doesn't matter.
They're just faceless personas
who are playing
your game right now.
So long story short, unless you
care about who the players
are outside of the game, just
use participant ID, which is
something that every single
participant is going to have
and is going to be unique.
So, hopefully, that part of the
code is a little clearer
now that we know what player
ID and participant ID are.
And that's for the purposes
of that match.
So notice that it's pointless
to store that for a future
match because that doesn't
make any sense.
All right.
Now we are ready to play.
This is the fun part.
I know that we are Googlers,
so our definition of fun is
probably different from
the rest of the world.
But to us, fun really
means sending and
receiving byte arrays.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Whoo!
Yeah.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Byte arrays.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
I'm so excited.
I love byte arrays.
Who doesn't love byte arrays?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yes.
So, exactly, as far as our API
is concerned, that's what game
play really is.
The participants in the game are
changing just byte arrays
back and forth.
They're opaque to us.
We don't know what they mean.
There are sequences of bytes.
And it's up to your game to
define what they mean.
Now, there are two types of
messages that we carry for
you, which are reliable
messages
and unreliable messages.
So the reliable messages are
guaranteed to get to the
destination, while the
unreliable ones are probably
going to get there.
To summarize the differences,
reliable messages definitely
do get delivered and they are
delivered in the same order
that they are sent.
Now, for unreliable, they're
probably going to be
delivered, and the order is
probably going to be the same,
but your game should be prepared
for the cases where
that's not true.
And for both types of messages,
we do guarantee that
they will not get corrupted
or truncated.
So it's either delivered
exactly as you sent
it or not at all.
And this is how you send a
reliable real-time message.
Surprisingly, it's with
a method called
sendReliableRealTimeMessage.
So the first parameter is a
callback value if you want to
be notified of when the message
actually gets sent.
And then it's going to be the
message, which is just an
opaque byte [INAUDIBLE]
room ID, and participant ID.
Anyone want to risk a guess of
how the unreliable real-time
message method is called?
Correct.
sendUnreliableRealTimeMessage.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Somebody
got it out there.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So you call
SendUnreliableRealTimeMessage,
the parameters are the same
except you cannot provide a
callback because, after
all, it's unreliable.
So both of these methods also
have a corresponding broadcast
version which sends the same
message to everybody.
Notice that on the non-broadcast
version, you
have to specify who you
are sending it to.
And then on the broadcast
message, you don't have to.
Of course, for performance
reasons, we do recommend that
you only send the message to the
people that actually need
to receive them.
So don't send to everybody
unless you actually need to.
So how do you receive
a message?
Remember the callbacks that we
set up when we were specifying
that RoomConfig?
So that listener over there,
setMessageReceivedListener, is
the listener that's going to be
notified whenever you get a
real-time message.
So how do you implement
the callback?
So when you get the callback,
you can get the byte array
using rtm.getMessageData.
That's going to be the byte
array that the sender sent
exactly as they sent
it to you.
No need for checksums,
no need for anything.
We guarantee that that's going
to be exactly what they sent--
if that arrives at
all, of course.
And then, of course, you can
also use the real-time message
object to find out who sent
you the message, and
so on and so forth.
Now, over to Dan for some
important security and
performance advisory.
DAN RODNEY: So we have a few
caveats here just about
sending and receiving
messages.
So if you're like us and
you love byte arrays--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And
the environment.
DAN RODNEY: And the
environment.
Well, if you really love byte
arrays, you might be tempted
to make a new byte array
every time you
want to send a message.
But, if you do that, you will
cause lots of garbage
collection.
It's not good for performance.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Or
the environment.
DAN RODNEY: Or the
environment.
True.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: The
virtual environment.
DAN RODNEY: So try and create
one byte array and then reuse
it over time.
Don't allocate a new byte array
every time you want to
send a message.
That will litter the heap.
Similarly, you might be tempted
to take that byte
array and pass it around through
the rest of your code
when you receive a message.
But that byte array may get
reused and then weird things
might happen.
So instead, when you receive a
message, extract the data that
you need from that byte array,
and pass that back to the rest
of your program.
Don't keep that buffer around.
For the purposes of encoding
and decoding messages, make
sure you use something that's
fast for both serialization
and deserialization.
Here at Google, we recommend
protocol buffers.
There's a technology that
was invented at
Google that's very fast.
Some things like JSON are nice
to look at, but they won't be
as fast and won't be as
good for performance.
And, finally, the messages that
are sent between peers
are unencrypted.
So if the players in your game
are sending very sensitive
information, or there's some
reason that you really need to
be absolutely certain that the
data that's being sent back
and forth is authentic, you may
want to implement your own
security protocols on
top of our platform.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Actually, since
we are talking about
problems, let's talk about
some of the other
problems you may see.
So most of the problems have
to do with tunnels.
Yep, that's a tunnel.
I drew it.
And there are many of those
in the real world.
So you might get disconnected.
And that happens because, for
instance, you enter a tunnel.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
Nice graphic.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yep.
Advanced graphics.
It's like an X-ray vision
of a tunnel.
So your friend might get
disconnected, the friend
you're playing with.
Why?
Because they went through
a tunnel, of course.
So you have to deal with
that problem, too.
And the other problem has to
do with what's technically
known as meh.
So meh happens when I send an
invitation to a friend, yeah,
let's play this multiplayer
game.
And then they're like, meh.
And they decline
the invitation.
So you have to deal
with that problem.
Also, speaking about meh,
some friends are very
committed to games.
But some friends don't really
take games seriously.
I don't know why.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
Slackers.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yep.
So you're playing, and you're,
like, in the middle of a game,
and then they leave the game.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Usually
when they're behind.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah usually
when they're losing.
So how do you deal with that
kind of people, besides
unfriending them?
You should implement the various
callbacks provided by
the RoomStatusUpdateListener and
RoomUpdateListener to do
whatever it is right for your
game in each of these cases.
So sometimes you're going to
have to cancel the game.
Sometimes you can continue
with fewer players.
Of course, the logic of
that is up to you
and up to your game.
So it's important to listen for
onDisconnectedFromRoom,
which that tells you that you
are being disconnected from
your own room.
And then PeersDeclined,
PeersDisconnected, PeersLeft,
and there are actually a whole
bunch of others that might be
interesting depending
on your game.
So we definitely recommend you
to take a look at those
listeners and set up the
ones that make sense.
One word of warning-- if one
of more peers decline an
invite, you're never going
to get onRoomConnected.
You're never going to get
onRoomConnected because by
definition that only happens
when everybody is connected.
So if you still want to start
the game even though some
people have declined or left the
game, you're going to have
to manually monitor the
onPeersConnected callback to
know when it's the right
time to start the game.
Now, all we have to talk about
is the cleanup part, which is
the last part.
Now, you should always leave
the room after playing.
And that can be done by
calling leaveRoom.
After you do that, you have
to wait for the onLeftRoom
callback, which is going to
tell you that you have
successfully left the room.
And then at that point, and not
before, you can go ahead
and try to either create or
enter a different room.
Also, one important point is
don't forget to leave the room
one onStop.
Remember, with our current
design, you cannot remain in a
multiplayer game when our
application goes into the
background.
So if you get an onStop, you
should leave right away.
So how do you do that?
When you get the onStop
callback, you check if you are
in a room or not.
And then if you're inside a
room, you call leaveRoom to
leave that room.
That's going to guarantee that
the proper cleanup is made.
Now, I think we have pretty much
covered everything right
from sign-in, to get
people together, to
game play, to cleanup.
So we've covered even like
several paths through which
people can get people
together.
So they either list their
friends that they want to play
with, or they have
a Quick Game with
some unknown opponent.
We've shown how to solve Dan's
problem of excessive
popularity, where they have to
deal with too many invites
using an invitation inbox.
And then we talked about how to
wait for the connection and
then play, which to us, of
course, means sending and
receiving byte buffers.
And then we talked about
clean-up and how to get back
to your main screen.
And remember that you can do as
many rematches as you want
during the play phase because to
us, your game is just going
on as normal.
You don't have to do anything
special if you're trying to
rematch the same people
in the same room.
All right.
So where do we go from here?
Wolff knows where
we go from here.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Well,
where do we go from here?
Google Play game services
real-time
multiplayer can do a lot.
You can invite players from any
device in the world to any
other device in the world,
all across the world.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Did
I say world again?
Bring people together in rooms
by invitation or automatch,
stream messages over a mesh
network, peer to peer, or, in
some case, even go through
the Google network.
And it's all taken care of by
our back end, so you can focus
on making the best game
you possibly can.
You could start today.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: I mean,
effectively, we've given you
several reasons to start
today, right?
So, but of course, we don't want
you to walk out of this
talk thinking that--
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Without
a balanced perspective.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Without
balance.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: So we've
also compiled a list of
reasons that you shouldn't
start now.
You guys ready for this?
We're going to go fast.
DAN RODNEY: How are they
supposed to memorize that?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh,
don't worry.
I know that this list is long
and this is actually just the
first page.
But don't worry because
this is also available
online at this URL.
So you can just access that.
I like to set that
as my home page.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Yes.
Or Google.com.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Or Google.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: Yes.
So go forth and conquer.
We're waiting to see
awesome stuff.
If you make awesome stuff,
tell us about it.
We love to hear about it.
Thank you so much.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: We have
one, two possible thoughts
here-- three actually.
One, we'd love it if you
rate this session.
You can rate this session
in the Google I/O app.
Or you can scan that QR code
and tell us all about it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: In previous
I/Os, we actually supplied
real-life tomatoes
you could throw.
But then that made a mess.
So if you want to throw
tomatoes, or praise us, please
just scan that QR code over
there that says "Rate the
Session."
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON:
They're virtual.
We're not littering the heap
with these tomatoes.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: And then
the other thing is that
Bruno's going to keep talking
about more awesome
things you can do.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: I'm actually
going to keep talking for two
sessions now.
So if you enjoy listening
to me, you're going
to have a good time.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: If you
like Bruno, there's plenty of
Bruno to go around.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: If you don't
like to hear me talk, man,
you're going to have
a bad time.
DANIEL "WOLFF" DOBSON: And Dan
and I are going to head out
over to Office Hours.
All right?
Thanks a lot.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Thank you.